en alberta l'heure est encore aux
élections - deux mois après le scrutin
fédéral place aux élections municipales
car garé grande métropole
multiculturelle les villes tentent
d'encourager le plus grand nombre
possible d'électeurs aller voter si bien
que pour la première fois le guide des
électeurs envoyé à tous et traduit en
dix langues mais pas en français de
chercher partout dans 26 pages pour lui
dire qu'il devait y avoir quelque chose
en français quelques pas et yann on y
avait il y avait rien une surprise pour
cet électeur qui s'y plaît auprès
d'élections calgary pour justifier
l'absence de traduction française
l'organisme lui a répondu que en
majorité ceux qui parlent français parle
aussi anglais ils seront donc en mesure
d'obtenir les informations pour le vote
contenu dans le guide une affirmation
qui surprend eshop pierre floch endersen
c'est tellement honnête que c'en est
qu'on est obligé de sourire on peut
s'énerver mais l'honnêteté la brutalité
de l'honnêteté est incroyable mais pire
encore la raison évoquée pour ne pas
traduire en français le document est
erroné dit ceux qui travaillent auprès
des immigrants francophones de calgary
ils sont censés connaître la démographie
de la région nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup de clients qui parlent pas
anglais qui sont juste après une plainte
de l'association canadienne française de
l'alberta élections calgary indique que
la traduction française sera finalement
offerte est mise en ligne dans les
prochains jours mais c'est trop peu trop
tard koala président de la cfa c'est
décevant je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui va falloir continuer à
travailler avec l ex en cassant une
solution vraiment avant les prochaines
élections municipales dans 44 ans
selon le dernier recensement 25000
francophones vivent dans la métropole
albertaine et près de cent mille
personnes ils sont capables de parler
dans cette langue officielle ici mathieu
gaye et radio canada est maintenant